und die spd vorsitzende saskia esken ist
uns jetzt zugeschaltet einen schönen
guten morgen nach stuttgart guten morgen
wir uns gerade gesehen der
ministerpräsident von baden württemberg
winfried kretschmann lädt zum
gas-krisengipfel 1 da fragen sich viele
warum heißt der gastgeber nicht olaf
scholz und warum findet das nicht auf
nationaler ebene statt das findet auf
nationaler ebene statt da nennt es sich
konzertierte aktion der bundeskanzler
hat vertreter innen von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften eingeladen und fachleute
der sachverständigenrat ist mit dabei um
sich genau über diese fragen zu
unterhalten wie kann jetzt eine gasmenge
lage entgegengewirkt werden wo kann wie
gespart werden und wie und wo können wir
entlasten damit bürgerinnen und bürger
aber auch unternehmen unter den
mehrkosten die jetzt entstehen nicht den
spagat machen wobei ja bei der
konzertierten aktion die sie
angesprochen haben das thema er die
inflation war es gab keine konkreten
ergebnisse und das nächste treffen soll
erst im september stattfinden die
industrie setzt ja auf jeden fall auf
glühenden kohlen weil sie eben wissen
will braucht sich vorbereiten muss
bisher ist ja die linie der
bundesnetzagentur klar erst müsste bei
engpässen die industrie sparen dann die
privathaushalte wird es dabei bleiben
wenn das gas knapp wird die gesetzeslage
ist so auch auf europäischer ebene und
es ist ja auch ganz klar die
verbraucherinnen verbraucher können
nicht ausweichen diejenigen die mit gas
heizen die haben keine alternative
anders zu heizen jedenfalls nicht
diejenigen die nicht im einfamilienhaus
sitzen und deswegen müssen
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher auch
entsprechend geschützt werden das ist
unsere aufgabe dazu hat aber die
bundesregierung ja schon vor monaten
begonnen eben genau die
energieversorgung die energiesicherheit
auch anzugehen mit einem gasspeicher
gesetz mit dem energie sicherungs gesetz
und auch jetzt zuletzt auch mit der
möglichkeit eben kraftwerke kohle
kraftwerke wieder hochzufahren das heißt
wir tun ja schon alles was möglich ist
um die um die situation entsprechend
vorzubereiten und insofern geht es jetzt
bei der konzertierten aktionen bei
anderen gesprächen die geführt werden
regelmäßig und auch zwischen treffen und
zwischengipfel natürlich weiter in der
frage wie sichern wir die energie für
den für den herbst und winter und wie
entlasten wir die menschen von mir kurz
es gibt ja auch noch andere vorschläge
fressen wie man die energieknappheit im
herbst ausgleichen soll wir können uns
mal anhören was der oppositionsführer
und cdu vorsitzende friedrich merz
gestern im zdf sommerinterview gesagt
hat und zwar zum thema kernenergie
ich sage ihnen voraus wir werden am ende
des jahres sehen was die laufzeit der
kernkraftwerke verlängert wird gibt es
vorgeschlagen die bundesregierung gehen
wenn die bundesregierung mit uns reden
will ernsthaft reden was sie zurzeit
nicht tot wir bieten das immer an aber
wir laufen der bundesregierung nicht
hinterher
hat der cdu vorsitzender recht wird es
eine verlängerung der laufzeiten der
drei verbliebenen atomkraftwerke
vielleicht dann doch geben
das wirtschaftsministerium als teil der
bundesregierung hat ja schon zu beginn
des jahres eine abschätzung dazu
vorgenommen und wird jetzt nochmals
prüfen inwieweit strikt betriebe und
ähnliches was da vorgeschlagen wird
hilfreich sein können wir sind an der
stelle nicht so ideologisch unterwegs
aber ganz klar ist auch alle argumente
die bisher gegen die atomkraft
gesprochen haben und die dazu geführt
haben dass wir den ausstieg beschlossen
haben zweimal zunächst die rot-grüne
regierung
2001 und dann nochmal die eine schwarz
gelbe regierung die gelten ja weiterhin
das ist immer noch keine lösung gefunden
für die endlagerung des atommülls und
viele andere fragen sind auch nicht
geklärt schauen wir noch mal darauf sie
haben sie auch eben angesprochen wie die
bundesregierung die mehrbelastungen
durch die energie krise abfedern will
der bundeskanzler hat dauerhafte
entlastungen für verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher und für die industrie
angekündigt angesichts der
explodierenden preise bleibt aber die
frage wie will er das finanzieren noch
dazu wo 2023 ja eigentlich wieder die
schuldenbremse gelten soll ja da kommt
es jetzt ganz entscheidend darauf an
dass wir nach den massiven
entlastungsmaßnahmen die die
bundesregierung ja schon vorgenommen hat
in höhe von 30 milliarden euro von denen
viele jetzt im juli auf dem konto
ankommen wie wir danach eben auch für
dauerhafte preise entlastungen möglich
machen können die kann in den
allermeisten fällen nicht der staat
leisten deswegen muss es darum gehen die
einkommen zu erhöhen wir haben die den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro erhöht das ist
beschlossen da kommt zum ersten oktober
und wir können davon ausgehen dass löhne
die da in der nähe sich bewegen
tariflöhne dass die natürlich dann auch
steigen werden die
gebäudereinigungsbranche hat es bereits
vorgemacht und dort wo wir helfen können
das sind die sozialleistungen das müssen
wir auch dass unsere aufgabe menschen zu
unterstützen die sich an das nicht und
die sich selbst nicht helfen können die
über keine rücklagen verfügen da müssen
wir anpacken das ist das bürgergeld und
das ist eben das wohngeld das modell
soll ausgeweitet werden und es soll auch
erhöht werden und das ist dringend
notwendig um menschen mit geringen und
mittleren einkommen zu unterstützen aber
frau essen ich habe gefragt wie alt das
finanziert werden soll dazu haben sie
jetzt gar nichts gesagt sie brauchen
noch entweder höhere einnahmen sprich
höhere steuern oder müssen mehr schulden
machen um all diese leistungen die sie
jetzt gerade noch mal beschrieben haben
auch zu finanzieren ja wir haben ende
den vergangenen drei jahren ja bereits
eine ausnahme von der schuldenbremse
gezogen die steht die ausnahme genauso
wie die schuldenbremse selbst in der
verfassung ich bin der ziemlichen festen
überzeugung dass die dass die
krisenlage die wir die letzten drei
jahre hat noch nicht überwunden ist und
die neue krisenlage nämlich der krieg da
kommt noch hinzu insofern beständig
schon in frage dass wir schon wieder zu
einem normalen zu einem nicht
krisenhaften haushalt zurückkehren
können ganz klar ist aber auch es sind
in den letzten jahren hohe gewinne
gemacht worden über gewinne wie man sagt
eben gewinne die nicht mit eigener
leistung mit eigener innovation zu tun
haben sondern die einfach nur der krise
geschuldet sind eine über gewinn steuer
wäre insofern auch eine möglichkeit die
aktuelle situation in der aktuellen
situation finanzierungsmittel
herbeizuschaffen oder eben auch die sehr
hohen vermögen die auch in den letzten
zwei jahren um 20 prozent gestiegen sind
das hat mir noch einmal fest sie stellen
also die schuldenbremse für das kommende
jahr in frage das war saskia esken die
spd vorsitzende im interview heute
morgen vielen dank gern